et du coup on va jouer et que vous les
chroniqueurs et vos rupture alors il ya
des ruptures qui vont apparaître
à votre avis quelles ruptures correspond
à quelques chroniqueurs à ce qu'on peut
faire apparaître les rues j'ai là d'une
personne par courrier mail ne l'a jamais
reçu alors par courrier ça a moins vite
que ça devait être un télégramme ça doit
être isabelle morini-bosc non à la
larguer de personnes isabelle combien
nord alors a pu être j'ai largué une
personne par pigeon voyageur mais n'a
rien reçu je me suis fait larguer qu'à
mon conjoint avait envie de me claquer
quand je parle et ça ça mon avis c'est
maxime kenny lala pour tout de suite
nos gars j'ai largué quelqu'un car il
était toujours d'accord avec moi alors
ça c'est vous non ouais quelqu'un par
contre je vais virer quelqu'un parce que
ça me déchire
je me suis fait larguer par texto en
pleine nuit j'ai largué quelqu'un à
cause de l'odeur de ses pieds ça sympa
j'ai largué la personne qui a piraté la
messagerie
je me suis fait larguer à cause du
monstre du loch ness alors ça c'est
isabelle morini-bosc je suis annoncé jjg
je me suis fait larguer parce que je
n'avais pas assez pas pris assez
poitrine isabelle c'est bon j'ai largué
quelqu'un à cause de madonna ça alors un
mytho pareil ça peut être que de leurs
maux je me suis fait larguer parce que
je travaillais trop on se tait sur ce
n'est pas jean michel maire alors les
cherry avait démarré alors marié et baba
et à votre avis c'est fait j'ai largué
une personne par courrier mais ne l'a
jamais reçu moi je pense ici
moi j'aurais puisque je connais pas les
réponses si moi j'aurais dit christine
kelly pas du tout raté à moi j'aurais
dit gilles verdez parce qu'il a le
physique de quelqu'un qui écrit des
lettres des mains
je vois bien la plus comme se plaît à
l'appeler - non non c'est un bon alors
mais julien courbet du lacombe et suis
l'un de ses voix et barbara les très
fortes bravo sérieux elle a grillé
castaldi l'a bien préparé l'émission a
été très fort dans à la halle à ces
mêmes salariés
attention explique tu fais un écart
faire tu rentres à la maison cet été ou
par le port et à l'est par le pen qui
dit la barbe en fait des antennes mais
c'est vrai très fort alors julien dray
ont une histoire bête od partir en
vacances et j'en avais un petit peu
marre donc j'ai écrit une lettre avec
les bêtises habituel qui est trop bien
pour moi et ses barrières
et une grève donc elle n'a pas reçues
donc s est pointé les jours après j'ai
quand même dû partir en vacances donc
mais non les enquêtes et les vacances
c'est à dire c'est passé deux jours où
elle a su quand elle est rentrée mais
entre temps de la main propre entre
tortola alors autant jouer expliqué sur
place sur le lieu de vacances aref
aurait été sympa j'ai donné un ticket
train pour qu'elle rentre attention
[Applaudissements]
vous adore parce que babar ali lebhar
elle rigolé quand il a dit aux travaux
le coquen espèce de gros cons le vendeur
est alors je me suis fait larguer car
mon conjoint avait envie de me claquer
quand je parle de moi moi je pense que
ces magistrats max non moi ouais moi jle
ou max c max moi je pense non maxime
gagnon a parlé même halo maxime pas fait
une phrase qui bouge
panda cloud jour je suis très content
d'être là oui c'est vous c'est moi
non c'est vous c'est moi c'est vous oui
voilà oui si tel double à quoi donc elle
avait envie de vous claquez quoi ça
s'adapte diakhaté enchanté avec une
charmante rouquine très propre service
où elle est une fois qu'on est du
service d'hygiène m'ont paru en avait
plein de points en commun surtout la
bonne bouffe
elle avait une petite particularité ce
qu'elle ne voulait m'embrasser que sur
la lèvre du bas elles leur place et à
chaque fois donc je l'embrassé que le
haut donc c'était un petit détail
en tout cas on s'entendait bien buenos
aires on voit les écrevisses et là tu
discernement soit de demain n'en fait
pas après deux manches le bas après
après demain je peux pas et au final
elle m'a envoyé un sms en disant j'ai
envie de te claquer quand tu me parles
je ne supporte pas ta voix j'ai
l'impression d'avoir à faire un
présentateur à longueur de journée ah
ouais bah je la comprends voilà c'est ça
et depuis on sait ça m'évite elle est
repartie avec son ex non ils sont
j'étais très triste par onex paraît que
c'est bernard merci je m'en vais y fait
partie avec son homologue jean michel
maire il est ou non michel tu peux
revenir je viens de voir sur 66 midi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
alors j'ai largué quelqu'un qui en
réalité toujours d'accord avec moi qui
tuent sans sa barbe à isabelle elle aime
pas quand on est d'accord avec elle aime
le débat allait mlle de l'empiré benhaim
mois est-ce que benhaim ja connais un
peu et elle aime bien les mecs qui ont
de la poigne
allez vous me connaissez bien oui c'est
moi a dit mme soumise mais non justement
j'en ai mais y en a pas un qui comprend
vous avez la regarder oui enfin je
roulais vous voulez que je dise ça c'est
assez horrible il était trop gentil
c'est chiant c'était voilà donc du coup
c'est calme plat c'est trop il est trop
trop trop gentil tu dis la terre est
plate il te dis oui d'un certain point
de vue elle est plate donc quand même
pas 10 on peut pas cela correct on a un
peu de prises un peu de voile a été
soumise les trottoirs il ya aussi ou pas
il est très gentil moi mais jamais trop
pas trouvé parfois on est d'accord parce
qu'on n'est pas d'accord
sinon je suis fan marié vraiment à
boujan toujours là et je te jure qu'il
ya plein de potes à moi tu sais que
c'est un exemple parce que tu as plein
de mecs qui disent arié elmaleh la bande
de möbius jure que c'est vrai parce que
je suis impressionné par lui parce que
il me rappelle quand j'étais petit les
potes de mon frère je t'ai toujours
impressionné c'est la bande démontrait
je ne rigole pas pour nous à chaque fois
on prend un exemple avec la bande
candidats banc de thons cap ce qu'on dit
a renié c'est le mec qui dit des
bouquins mais il est sympathique et
politique
il parle bien ce jour pour nous c'est
dans la maison ainsi si juste un exemple
pour nous on a je mets alors je me suis
fait largo est largué par texto en
pleine nuit on sait que c'est pas
isabelle jusqu'à l'art bebop
donc je me suis fait larguer par texto
ça casse a dit ouais j'étais sûr je te
jure eh bien à castaldi ouais parce que
kertel ni en pleine nuit je vois bien ce
faire la mairie est exactement en fait
je des parts et par quelle femme l'a
lancé
alors c'était non je souhaitais c'était
ma femme dé bonne foi
c'était ma femme et ma femme en fait et
sa quête je ne peux pas vous le dire
mais bon c'est fait la différence alors
c'est comme ça que wes cates a dégagé
par sms non à la décrue oui et oui en
fait je partais je faisais la matinale
sur une radio rtl2 l2 tu as fait et je
partais assez tôt le matin et je
revenais donc après l'émission et je
faisais une petite sieste
parce que j'étais fatigué et j'ouvre mon
téléphone et j'ai ce texte au khimki me
dit voilà c'est fini
bon on a eu des cardeurs radio ils sont
passés bon je te le dire voilà et non
c'était incroyable et votre femme elle
doit quitter paraissait loin
ouais c'est ouf ça fait ouf mais j'en
rigolais je veux que cela
ouais ouais flavie et sans explication
banon mais yahia mois ya bien deux ans
j'étais pas j'étais pas exemplaire non
plus mais mes délires non la pression
mais pas le parfait démarrer mais c'est
vrai que c'est assez violent le texto
pour barrer ben c'est sûr que passer
votre femme
non non c'était assez concis ouais parce
qu'il n'est pas bien la soirée cc c'est
fort je suis très fort de se faire
larguer par sa femme parisienne elle
c'était vraiment chaud c'était un assez
beau message d'azur ah ouais j'aime pas
ta gueule il a gardé le même assez bonne
avec christelle aventure drame c'était
mes jambes ne me portent plus je sais
qu'il prendra son hub petit canard je
peux je m'en vais à orthez
allez tout droit normalement vous avez
trouvé chaumât nous appartient le ton
dès ce matin voilà ok mais c'est fou ça
alors j'ai là j'ai largué quelqu'un à
cause de l'odeur de ses pieds ça c'est
quelqu'un c'est vraiment ça ouais ouais
quand ce sens que l al aryane sur pour
saquer moi je pense à gesink faisant les
frais ces visas mais non mais non mais
non
alors c'est marrant fermeture en france
avant le match je le vois sur madonna
s'est voulu me recruter
jean michel c'est jean-michel massa doit
être bayam amie kelly oui c'est beau
mais c'est mais on l'a oublié celle ci
n'a jamais oublié c'est sympa mais oh ça
va tu vas tu te donne pas en spectacle a
alors dit nous non oui c'est vrai que
c'était à deux trois ans voilà j'ai
rencontré un garçon il m'a invité à voir
le foot bon déjà je suis pas fan du foot
et j'ai dit ok j'ai fait un futur aux
fans de foot un moment absolument pas ce
que je fais un effort je vais marier à
d'autres avec un jour là allez allez aaa
mais non mais pas une phase aller ben
oui bah diététique 2 bref quoi l'atelier
vous ça va à l'essai qui était passionné
par le foot bref on s'en fout et même du
coup au final j'y suis allé j'ai fait un
effort j'ai pu voir la personne
ouais je l'installé tout il enlève ses
chaussures et là je me dis mais c'est
pas possible mais ça sent les poubelles
ça sent le fromage les poubelles non
c'est pas possible
bon je regarde quand même le match je
prends sur moi et le lendemain je
retourne le voir et appareils la même
chose ils enlèvent si je suis pas le mec
en fait il voulait absolument mais je
suis le cabinet des pieds c'est pas une
mais des bottes
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
tu le sais tu veux en bosnie mais des
après-ski annoncions bas mais les cas
vive absolument qui sait comme les gars
qui pue de la gueule ils valent
absolument vous dire des secrets au
final je me suis dit c'est plus possible
donc j'ai tenu la soirée parce que je
suis quelqu'un de poli et je n'ai pas
dit mais lendemain j'ai envoyé un
message et lui dit c'est pas possible tu
pues de quoi oui honnêtement je vais pas
du genre non je lui ai dit j'ai des
problèmes avec l'hygiène parfois lassé
enfin si je lui ai dit ah bon ça peut
s'arranger depuis louis
j'ai assez canon les gens qui aient pu
dominer plus plu ici les laves puis puis
des pieds n'ont pas fait d'études jeter
l'argent
elle rentrait à l'arrivée chez lui
coincé dans la touche
non c'est lui c'est lui qui les dit
bachir excuse moi je vais pas les laver
parce que ça va encore plus plus c'est
ça le méritant et embrouiller son accord
et je savais déjà
en tout cas bravo belle enquête bélanger
j'ai gardé la personne qui apprirent à
traiter la paix raté ma messagerie
estime que 10 à wayne et j'adore j'ai
l'impression qu'avec kaka cl oui c'est
qu'on retourne tous fait un bond en
arrière tu penses à cette histoire est
en fait j'étais présentatrice elle sait
y avait quelqu'un qui paie raté ma
messagerie ma boîte vocale mes mails on
avait porté plainte avec le groupe tf1
on a été vraiment ont porté plainte et
tout est un jour
c'est à dire et messagerie comment c'est
à dire mais c'est à dire que tu écoutes
des messages vont se dit à 15 ans tu
écoutais message second te dis que tu as
ta boîte vocale des huit messages
et puis tu te dis que tu vas les écouter
après et puis tu quand tu les écoutes
vous n'avez aucun nouveau message ou
bien encore quelqu'un qui répondait aux
téléspectateurs à ma place non donc les
téléspectateurs moi je répondais à
l'entamé et il répondait à ma place
ouais donc là mais j'étais déjà je me
suis dit c'est un téléspectateur qui me
petits pirates mais non mais c'était
tétanisés mais tétanisés
tu as vraiment l'impression qu'ils
accusent suis tout et puis tous les
collègues me demandez à laure mais alors
tu en es où etc on m'emmène porté
plainte et c est tout et puis un jour tu
te rends compte que l'ennemi est dans
ton lit non les étoiles et sur ma vie on
dirait un film tourné les lignes
urbaines un jeu en fait c'est mon mari
je vois la bande alors la question à
wilrijk nombre était bon mari ah ouais
venetz maristes vous êtes 2 - jours
malgré ces imams et c'était mon deuxième
mariage il m'amenait et me dit écoute ça
tu as quelqu'un dans ta vie mais en plus
c'était tellement faux j'allais me
marier je terme ou russes comme dans
mais il était jaloux de plus de chf
je me suis levé votre donnez-moi
diatement oui certains d'entre vous et
castaldi
[Applaudissements]
mais à la seconde près je me suis levée
et c'était et je suis parti comme non
non il était bien il est ravi mais non
mais quand tu vois que wright et de
rattraper le coup
ah oui les a beaucoup vraiment pas la
mort c'était pas possible parce que je
tue tout au tout si tu veux tous les
collègues étaient témoins de salta tu te
fais violer entre guillemets ta
messagerie tout non mais tu veux pas
répondre de téléspectateurs et puis tu
vois que tous les soins mais c'est lui
poids c'est fin c'est lui qui a fouillé
qui fouillent tous non mais je sais
c'est et ses briques travail à la
foir'fouille mais c'était bien trouvé je
me suis fait larguer à cause du monstre
du loch ness
c'est une métaphore sur le sexe masculin
n'ont pas eu droit tout magazine mode tu
vas trouver des dépôts nes equidia oui
alors c'est nous c'est moi bah oui nous
sommes en 1993
nous sommes alors fois nous sommes nous
sommes en 1993 en écosse sur les bords
du loch ness
je vis une amourette naissante avec
catherine que je viens de rencontrer et
catherine me dit nous sommes au début de
la relation j'aime l'histoire
j'ai dit mais c'est génial je vais
t'emmener chercher le monstre du loch
ness ça c'est de l'histoire
donc nous partons j'organise cinq jours
près d'inverness en écosse pour aller
chercher le monstre du loch ness
vous savez qu'il existe et personne n'a
encore trouvé et ouais c'est pas beau
tout un peu comme dans tous les deux et
il pleut pendant trois jours le déluge
vous avez tous beaucoup de chance et moi
j'ai repensé le lac avec catherine comme
ça autour pour trouver le monde au back
droit genre le média goudjil c'est plus
possible moi je partais pour un petit
séjour romantique se voit jamais on
poursuit ce [ __ ] de monde j'en ai rien
à faire n'était pas dans ton et une
super idée pourtant de l ces métropoles
qui était pas la société
on veut s'arroger
[Musique]
[Rires]
aulas il faut que je cours beaucoup au
bout de trois jours elle me dit écoute
c'est plus possible n'a rien à jouer à
nos jeux
je te laisse avec ton monte et moi je
repars à paris est elle repartie à paris
et je suis très fier parce que j'ai
continué à chercher le monstre et
voulait non mais s'il le faut je
retournerai balesi merci belle histoire
franchement barbara elle est à fond
dedans je me suis fait larguer parce que
je n'avais pas à ce prix assez poitrine
isabelle alias et moi c'est moi
alors oui et non on vous sait madonna je
suis en alsace en commun et ça peut pas
être vrai tu en as plus que moi mais
vous vous la poitrine oui mais ça ne
nous était plus tôt
madonna sera temps de cela m'a mis sur
le bateau de slam c'est cyril théreau
mais sur le fond il a raison
effectivement qu'ensuite ça j'ai déjà
l'air d'être de dôme et c'est j'avais 11
ans espère que j'avais 11 ans et j'avais
un garçon qui était qui m'aimait
vraiment beaucoup aimé 18 n'est pas joli
pour l'instant de toute crise est tout
noir au de méditer tout ce joli petit
par joly pour l'instant mais dans 4 50
tu sera parfaite
tu auras prix de la poitrine tôt rappelé
l'effort visionnaire à 4,510 donc à 11
ans nommé avec l âge
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moi s'il vous plaît entendez votre
place au standard place à merci c'est
gentil merci
alors oui alors donc oui je sais
l'histoire elle va du elle est longue
mais un fait remarquer que j'ai dit une
phrase un poulain alain oddo plusieurs
îles avec l âge ben dis donc toi
il avait vidé la grève air vous savez
que je suis un mec à 11 ans mais on
était des plus des petits fiancée comme
vous avez un serment et visionner le
tourne souvent autour de moi très mais
elle est où nous avons donc passé que la
bouche mais on s'embrassait bah oui non
et c'est vrai mais c'est le truc le plus
accessible qu'on a beaucoup vanté
l'huile avec nuages mais sans la langue
on croyait que le vrai réseau routier
dans les tranchées et on était
[Applaudissements]
et on existe le sco s'appelait christian
belz toujours rappelé christian
meilleurs artistes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici un petit peu avec notre plateau
question est donc et donc j'ai grandi de
partout et il était vraiment désespéré
parce que à 14 ans j'avais effectivement
grandi en jambes en taille en derrière
en épaule mais alors la poitrine
quasiment un par un et quand il s'est
rendu compte un jour il n'a pas parié
jour j'arrive technique
il a vraiment mesuré sur l'a10 à ton
pain il a vraiment mesuré et il a vu
qu'elle n'avait plus en omoplates
derrière caen 5-2 vendredi ce qu'un jour
tu as l'intention de faire quelque chose
du ballon j'en reviens radio am derrière
mais pas augmenter la patrie ni les
bombes écoute merci au revoir
il a prié comme si une fille qui avait
la plus grosse poitrine du lycée qu'il a
fini par laisser tomber parce qu'avant
je l'avais déjà à la taille car il monte
ma mère on va laisser au bout du rouleau
mais c'est moi j'ai décroché
quant à lui voilà quelqu'un à cause de
madonna on sait que c'est de l'ormeau en
revanche souple et je me suis fait
larguer parce que je travaillais trop
voyant mes deux minutes je me suis fait
c'est vous c'est quoi la surprise
m'attendait vous êtes fait larguer parce
que vous travaillez exact exacerbée dans
une vie antérieure à bages vous
raconterez dans un sex-shop pas retrouvé
mon monde trompe son monde ne comprend
pas ce que vous dites mon monde
alors aidez nous alors c'est une
fâcheuse habitude reconnaissez quand je
rentre de tpm pejak chez moi je repasse
ses missions pour débriefer pour essayer
d'améliorer dont je repasse sous par
quart d'heure et je séquence toute
émission et genre là où j'aurais dû dire
ça alors je vois du mucus travail etc et
je prends des notes s'apprend pas quoi
vous allez avoir un avantage année
prochaine vous allez pouvoir la voir en
direct
et ça vous allez voir vous allez kiffer
maire sa quête de l'amour vous êtes fait
larguer vous avait largué quelqu'un
cause de madonna c'est quoi cette
histoire
la wii s'est très vite très vite fait
très vite ouais en fait j'avais un
copain à l'époque s'appelait alexis et
dana coiffure mais pas quand coiffeur
mais c'est pas le dossier d'aquarium et
paris maintenant oui mais en fait c'est
lui c'est avec ces il avait une petite
chienne cocker roux qui s'appelait
madonna alsacienne d'accord à chaque
fois qu'on était ensemble
madonna était père agressive avec moi
ouais un jour où on fait des choses à ma
méthode peu la couverture on fait les
choses un peu plus coquine sur un canapé
ah oui madonna mais man le mollet
[Rires]
alors moi je m'énerve jeudi alexis
maintenant c'est madonna au moi et m'a
dit si tu m'aimes
c'est un que c'est un lot c'est madonna
et moi il m'a dit faut le choisir
j'écoute moi je ne choisis pas les deux
j'ai donc finalement il m'a dit moi je
garde madonna il m'a largué non il a
préféré tiennent à vous il préférait
madonna a à moi j'ai écouté les rues
novelli dire jaillir le cheikh brahim
j'ai de quoi charmer mieux la cus
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ils arguent les bleus c'est très drôle
la belle saison et l'ouest ou moins
dépendants du mais c'est sympa